check out this week's must-see movies  three animals grow to enormous size and  threaten the world in ramping dare make  a little Livia let's get this party  started  a game between friends becomes deadly in  truth or dare do we get there or you  died screw this and you die find a new  buddy Conroy the sergeant wanted a  mascot give the unit a different look  the true story of the most decorated dog  in American military history is told in  sergeant stubby and American Hero  you could all learn something from him  see what's hot in theaters with this  week's fantasy patient  [Music]  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know by commenting see you  next time on weekend ticket  [Music]